ich habe so den Eindruck eigentlich
schon seit einiger Zeit es gibt ja den
alten Spruch am deutschen Wesen soll die
Welt genesen ich bin jetzt bescheid an
meinen Eindruck über diese Ampel ist am
grünen Wesen soll Deutschland genesen
und die Ampel genesen und wehe jemand
macht nicht mit dann ist er ein
Störenfried und dann wird Bashing
Betrieben exaltiert natürlich vor allen
Dingen in dem Ausbruch von Robert Habeck
in den Tagesthemen was in meinen Augen
für für einen Mitglied und ein
Vizekanzlerin einer Koalition völlig
unmöglich ist dass er praktisch der
eigenen Regierung Handlungsunfähigkeit
attestiert dass er sagte die tragen
keine Verantwortung nur wir tragen sie
das ist das was ich bei den Grünen seit
längerem schwer kritisiere das ist eine
Anmaßung das ist eine Überheblichkeit
die natürlich nicht richtig ankommt das
merken sie nur nicht und die bei der
Klimapolitik mir auch immer deutlicher
macht früher gab es ja mal den schönen
Spruch die Grünen sein so eine zweite
liberale Partei das war immer ein Irrtum
die Grünen sind nicht nur in meinen
Augen glaube ich wenn es darauf ankommt
wenn es um ihre missionarischen Ziele
sie wissen ja immer was gut für die
Menschen ist die der Rest weiß es ja
eigentlich nicht so dann neigen sie ganz
stark zu autoritären Strukturen dann
wird vorgeschrieben und in dieser ganzen
Klimapolitik kritisiere ich nicht und
das tut ja auch die Ampel insgesamt
nicht dass ihr ein Klimawandel haben
dass wir ihn bekämpfen müssen dass wir
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen brauchen aber in
welchem Tempo und und mit welchen
Methoden in welchem Preis und dann am
Ende natürlich auch um welchen Preis
bitte doch immer wenn ich einen Demokrat
bin dann indem wir die Menschen
mitnehmen aber im Augenblick habe ich
das Gefühl die schüttel nur noch den
Kopf und uns fühlen sich überfordert
plötzlich kompliziten aus dem Busch
den heizungsverbot für Öl und und
Gasheizung das mag ja mal vorm Jahr
irgendwo mal in einem koalitionsgespräch
diskutiert worden sein plötzlich kommt
das aber daher morgen müsst ihr eure
Heizung alle austauschen wenn ihr noch
ein neues Haus bauen wollt die meisten
haben wahrscheinlich auch gedacht gilt
auch für die alten das ist ja völlig
untergegangen dann plötzlich sagt man
wir haben zwar ein Kohle Kompromiss 2018
38 aber in Nordrhein-Westfalen das ja
geklappt mit 20 30 dann können wir das
doch auch im Osten machen und im Osten
ist natürlich das Kopfschütteln groß
weil die Infrastruktur und die
Möglichkeiten andere Jobs zu kriegen
sind ganz anders viel unterentwickelter
als in Nordrhein-Westfalen das alles
überfordert die Menschen und wenn sie
überfordert sind dann wenden sie sich ab
und wenn dann SPD und FDP ist ja eine
ein bisschen bequeme Ausrede der Grünen
das immer alles nur die FDP Schultern
sind die SPD weiß ja auch warum sich
zurückhält noch glaube ich hat sie schon
ein Interesse arbeiten immer bei sich zu
halten und nicht irgendwo zu verlieren
die Grünen müssen wir endlich mehr
Bescheidenheit lernen in meinen Augen
weniger nur wir wissen was richtig ist
auch die anderen wissen es mal und
vielleicht ein bisschen Luft aus dem
Kessel nehmen ein bisschen Dampf aus dem
Kessel nehmen ein bisschen Ruhe mehr
reinbringen etwas mehr das Tempo
verlangsamt mag ja sein dass wir zu
viele Jahre vertrödelt haben das
rechtfertigt aber nicht dass man jetzt
über die Köpfe der Bürger hinweg
entscheidet und das ist eine eine
Neigung bei den Grünen die dazu führt
dass die Leute an demokratischen
Spielregeln auch verzweifeln
und zwar die Frage ist natürlich
überrascht sie das Verhalten der Grünen
oder war das immer klar mit Blick auf
diese Koalition nein das überrascht mich
überhaupt nicht der Grüne haben eine
lange autoritäre Tradition seit ihrer
Gründung und beide Gründung waren auch
nationale Elemente dabei wie ist die
Frau die sich mit ihrem Freund gebracht
hat der Freund war ein General na
Bastian und
ich habe die zufällig kennengelernt ich
habe selten Leute getroffen dieser
autoritär waren Petra kellygeil doch so
als der Friedensengel die hat doch auch
diese ganzen Bilder es war noch man sagt
doch dass die Grünen vor allem in der
Anfangsphase so großes Marketing hatten
mit Petra Kelly dieser Frau mit den
Plakaten das weiß ich nicht ich weiß nur
dass sie im täglichen Umgang in der
Gesellschaft andere Leute vollkommen
autoritär war und nichts anderes hat
gelten lassen auch ein Friedensengel
kann auch autoritär war
der Weg vom totalen Krieg zum totalen
Frieden ist wahrscheinlich kürzer als
wir glauben und man muss nicht bis zu
Petra Kelly zurückgeben dass ich den
Namen vergessen habe es reicht sich die
Reden von Karin Erkrath anzuhören ich
meine abgesehen davon dass es nur 15 €
kostet den Namen zu ändern was ich an
ihre Stelle unbedingt machen würde man
muss heute nicht gehören heißen nein
wissen Sie Ihre Äußerung wir bekommen
Menschen geschenkt und alles was im
Umfeld der Willkommenskultur gesagt hat
das war nackte Autoritarismus oder
Totalitarismus auf Kosten auf dem Rücken
dieser armen Leute die nicht wussten was
hier erwartet die Grünen sind die
Erfahrung Garden nächsten Diktatur wenn
es denn eine geben sollte aber er Bruder
hat sie dann nicht gewundert dass die
FDP mit den Grünen gemeinsame Sache
gemacht hat weil bei Jamaika hat Helena
noch gesagt lieber nicht regieren als
falsch reagiert
und in dem Moment war ich kurz davor in
meine treue auf ewig zu versichern aber
daran hält er sich nicht mehr findet
immer noch wissen sie es gibt Leute die
machen bei irgendwas mit bei der SED
oder bei der KPD früher bei der NSDAP um
das Schlimmste zu verhüten das ist eine
selbe geliebte Phrase ich bin damit auch
groß geworden unter meinen linken
Freunden das ist immer nur eine Ausrede
für ein moralisch gerechtfertigt also
mitmachen der Hintergrund war natürlich
ein bisschen ein anderer
er hat die jamaika-warnung platzen
lassen weil die Kanzlerin wirklich nur
noch die Grünen gepäppelt hat und du als
FDP wirklich den Eindruck hattest
wir finden hier gar nicht statt außer
dass wir Mehrheitsbeschaffer sein sollen
aber es war trotzdem richtiger Satz ja
den Satz bestreitet ja auch nicht ob die
Entscheidung am Ende richtig war darüber
kann man lange streiten ob man das
Wagnis nicht hätte eingehen können oder
sollen aber die Motivation war Diesel
und dann natürlich die Erkenntnis wenn
die Kanzlerin jetzt schon so die Grünen
umgangt dann wird das ganz schwer das
Regieren ganz schön ich habe eine
Fraktion die vier Jahre nicht im
Bundestag war alles neue Leute kann ich
der das eigentlich tun und das er hat
dann natürlich nie gesagt hat auch sonst
keiner gesagt aber das war gehört auch
mit zu dem Hintergrund und hier hat er
natürlich gesagt mit dieser CDU und nach
der Bundestagswahl können wir nichts
machen die war ja auch völlig
handlungsunternehmen völlig durch den
Wind aber es war immer ein Risiko
politik ist immer Risiko sie können ja
es ist aber Glücksspiel wir sind ja in
der in der Analyse der Grünen eine ich
ein Grunde eine strukturell autoritäre
Partei die das gerne überspielt wenn es
nicht so so ankommt gibt man sich sehr
liberal auch aber eine Partei die den
starken Staat propagiert das heißt der
Staat sorgt für Stabilität und
Sicherheit nicht das Individuum die FDP
hat ein ganz anderes Grundverständnis
überhaupt liberale die müssen ja noch
nicht mal in der FDP sein die haben das
Grundverständnis von Freiheit und
Eigenverantwortung insofern war für mich
immer klar irgendwann stößt das
aufeinander und führt zumindest zu
Konflikten der Koalition so wie es jetzt
ist
da bin ich nur allerdings der Meinung
Herr habe kriegt sie auf und fasst sich
nicht an die eigene Nase und das sollten
die Grünen wirklich auch mal tun das ist
nicht nur die FDP die das schwierig
macht und es ist auch nicht die SPD die
aus guten Gründen den Grünen ja nicht
unbedingt beißen die Koalition Herr
Bremer mann sowas würde ich gar nicht
gehen weil sie kann ja nur Borussia
alternative
Neuwahlen will erstens keiner
zweitens ist es der Weg zu neu waren ja
nicht ganz so einfach und
die CDU ist sie schon so weit
wird die CDU etwa das wäre ja eine Macht
theoretisch denkbare Konstellation als
Juniorpartner unter Scholz eine
Regierung bilden wir haben ja jetzt die
Situation die Energiewende wie sie schon
von der Frau Merkel eingeleitet wurde
ist offensichtlich gescheitert ja wir
stellen erst die Kernkraftwerke ab
fangen dann an die Kohlekraftwerke
abzustellen verbieten Fracking
importieren dann faking Gas aus den USA
machen uns abhängig von Russland leider
ist es bei den Grünen so wenn die sehen
dass der Weg oder dass sie da nicht
ankommen auf dem ihr weg dann sagen sie
wir müssen den Weg schneller gehen und
wenn sie sehen die Ideologie stimmt
nicht mit den Fakten überein dann sagen
die pech für die Fakten ja das ist das
nee noch auf einen Punkt zurückkommen
den Herrn Bremer gerade gesagt hat und
zwar der Punkt
Neuwahlen will ja niemand würden sie
damit gehen
ja weiß man nicht wie die ausgehen ich
muss einmal zurechtfertigung zur
Verteidigung der FDP sagen nicht weil
ich jetzt Mitglied bin aber ja bin ich
ja mit offenen Karten spielen
aber denn den Volker von ihm ich bin's
jetzt in letzter Zeit geworden weil er
sich wenigstens auf meine Frage
antworten also Neuwahlen würden sie auch
nicht wollen ich würde es nur dann
wollen wenn ich die Hoffnung hätte das
was besseres bei rauskommt und das
wissen wir nicht ob das der Fall ist im
Moment die wissen genau
was anderem zufrieden wissen sie es muss
ja nicht gleich besser sein also sie
sagen Neuwahlen werden
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht aber
ich glaube keiner weiß es und diejenigen
die sagen dass sie es wissen heucheln
und was die sie haben vollkommen recht
die wollen den Weg den sie noch nicht
gegangen sind schneller gehen die halten
sich eigentlich einen altes Prinzip
wissen
dann sagt er wenn ich einen Fehler mache
mache ich einen Fehler gleich noch mal
dann sieht das nach Programm aus und das
ist genau das was die machen ja ich
fahre im falschen Zug und steige nicht
aus nee verdammt gefährlich was die
machen natürlich nicht nur diese
Koalition sondern sie gefährden das
Vertrauen der Bürger in die
Regierungsfähigkeit in diesem Land und
das brauchen wir nun wirklich Angesicht
der tausend Krisen die es alle
gleichzeitig gehen
da hätte ich schon ganz gern dass man da
etwas sorgsamer mit umgeht und das werde
ich ihm eigentlich auch vor dieser
Ausdruck ist eines Vizekanzlers unwürdig
meine was Kopie gesagt hat ist auch
völliger Blödsinn dann kann ich nicht
mit Putin vergleichen hat sich ja auch
entschuldigt okay ja ja
weil Kopie passiert ja leicht mal so
etwas so ein bisschen überspitze
Formulierung aber es ist eines
Vizekanzlers unwürdig der schadet seiner
Koalition ohne dass die Grünen
Weiterkommen
er hatte ist ein Ausbruch und zum ersten
Mal seit langem richtig sympathisch weil
er mal einen hatte ein Minister hat auch
Gefühle da kann er kann verletzt sein da
hat Emotionen und gestern hatte sie
sozusagen als Mensch geoutet hier fragen
wir doch mal Herrn högele ganz kurz
möchte man als Bürger gerne Minister mit
Emotionen haben fühlen Sie sich gut
vertreten mag man das Emotionen also
prinzipiell finde ich sehr gut mit
Menschen überhaupt wo Emotionen zeigen
aber es ist ja immer so egal wo wir
hingehen gemeinsam will Spieler die nach
dem Bundesliga Spiel ihre Meinung sagen
das hat es auf der Zunge getragen aber
wer sie tun es kommt hinterher dann die
die beide Medienwelt und so reißt sie
zerlegt sie geh mal an die
Ministerpräsidentin in Neuseeland die
zwei sehr persönliche Situationen hatte
die danach soweit gedrängt wurde das
irgendwann auch für sich den Rücktritt
erwogen hat also man wünscht sich glaube
ich glaube also ich fühle mich als
Bürger wünschen und wenn die Qualität
haben
aber der ist ja menschlich ich meine er
repariert erhält Video reden wenn er
nach Kataris entschuldigt sich er
fotografiert auch immer seine Schuhe er
ist der menschlich also man muss sagen
Robert Habeck ist der menschlich das
menschliche das ist mag einfach aber ja
dann sollte die Kompetenz doch noch
heuer gehängt sein und äh da sehe ich
die große Probleme die Regierung ist von
uns beauftragt worden und das ist ein
Dienstleistungsbetrieb und wenn ich
wieder Autowerkstatt die ich besuche
nicht zufrieden bin gehe ich zu einer
anderen das gleiche geht für
ärztehandwerker Friseurin aber diese
Regierung doch die sind für Zeit berufen
und wenn sich abzeichnen dass sie den
Job nicht machen können dann müssen das
andere versuchen das ist ganz einfach
das ist Demokratie das passiert in
Holland alle sechs Wochen und die sind
schlecht
in Italien passierte das auch alle Nase
langweilig ist wissen wir
jetzt heute besser drauf als wir
naja weiß ich nicht auf jeden Fall ist
die Regierung arbeitet geräuschloser
obwohl man sich gerade bei der
Zusammensetzung sehr darüber erfordert
dass das so geräuschlos das liegt
vielleicht daran das ist eine Frau ist
die regiert aber bei Angela Merkel war
es ja auch nicht alles nur gut was Sie
was diese große Koalition gemacht hat
nein ich glaube es ist zu einfach
natürlich ist es im Prinzip richtig zu
sagen wenn jemand das nicht richtig
macht und soll er abtreten dann machen
wir was neues das ist nur bei uns Gott
sei Dank nicht ganz so einfach da
brauchst du viele Hindernisse im
Grundgesetz bevor du zu Neuwahlen kommst
und dann stellt sich wirklich die Frage
die haben sie ja auch gestellt was kommt
dann eigentlich wer kommt da eigentlich
und gibt dann eine Regierungsbildung
leichter zweier Koalition wird nicht
mehr geben außer die sogenannte Große
also ich glaube die Ampel soll sich eher
zusammenraufen und vernünftige Politik
machen eine Politik die bei denen die
Leute noch mitkommen und dann wird es
auch funktionieren würden sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie